oh nice the beer and videogames go
together like chips and salsa like
Doctor Who and the Daleks but up until
now your options for combining the two
up and well basically buy a six-pack
like this and bring it home and set it
next to your computer or if you're more
ambitious you get one of these like
little mini qeg things or if you're
really cool you can make a custom beer
robot like wired did and then there's
the arcade
so the great thing about the arcade is
that it's basically a classic arcade
video game simulator wrapped up in a
kegerator and it's got all these classic
old games like all the way from
asteroids and cows this on Mortal Kombat
Street Fighter 2 Santa pede Gunsmoke
rampage and like a good way that there's
a keg in there right on the side the
taps there you just pull a beer whenever
you want one what more could you want
maybe a cup holder oh yeah there is that
there's no good place to put your beer
because the panel is like kind of sloped
and when you get excited like this well
so here's the thing it isn't cheap but
if you have a lot of money I can't
really think of any better way to blow
it then on video games and beer really
there's one other downside about the
arcade which I will mention which is
that the capacity for the beer is not
really that great only holds one of
those little 5-gallon corny kegs and we
have some problems keeping our keg fully
cooled although I might have been user
error our keg is trying to help us sort
those things out another downside with
the beer dispenser is that there's no
rip tray underneath the little tap yeah
it makes us a messy game yeah so we had
to put a little thing down there to
catch all the drift because especially
as you get later in the evening you get
a little Messier pour in I've noticed
we've been staying a lot later I thought
there was a reason why work seems so
much more fun all of a sudden got you